daniel jones the top 10 draft pick of
the new york giants last year ultimately
became the starting quarterback sending
eli manning to the bench and then
into retirement eli manning appearing on
sirius xm nfl radio on tuesday opine
that he thinks it will be easier this
year for daniel jones to kind of step up
as that leader last year was probably
awkward for him me being there me being
in the meeting rooms and just kind of
the whole dynamic me being gone and hey
he's the quarterback he's the guy for
him to have that control and the
authority over receivers in the
offensive line the questions are coming
to him from the coordinator he's going
to have to give his voice and his
opinion on things that's eli manning
again yesterday on sirius xm nfl radio
and look
he's right he's absolutely right when
daniel jones walked in last year peter
daniel jones wasn't the guy eli was the
guy now eli's gone daniel jones is the
guy it changes everything
you know eli manning is such an adult
he really is he's he's just you know and
and i i'm gonna give most of my time
here to chris because chris understands
the dynamic of a quarterback room and he
should explain this but the one thing
that i've always so admired about eli
manning is that
no player
i've ever seen in my years covering the
nfl
sees the big picture the way eli manning
does
chris i'll leave it to you yeah well i'm
with you there though i mean eli is he
just got a great way about him and i
think that's why he was so well
respected by the giants organization and
guys in the locker room just unaffected
by anything always seems to see the the
cup half full uh and positive about no
matter what happens but this is a very
real dynamic i mean is when you're
talking about you know again first off a
young quarterback coming into a locker
room with a guy who's won two super
bowls and is the best quarterback in
franchise history
also you got to remember i mean hey in
football there's that military you know
militaristic uh respect for that right
keep trying yeah keep trying
i'll get it there eventually i'm not
worried about it but the big point that
i'm trying to get to
more than anything all right is just
that yes it's hard to take over a team
and be
i'm the leader and hey guys let's get in
the huddle and do this when there is
somebody like an eli manning there you
know when i went to tampa bay brad
johnson was there right he was the
starting quarterback for the bucks they
had just won the super bowl by my second
year i was kind of challenging brad
johnson for the starting spot and week
four they actually ended up gruden ended
up making the change and making me the
starter but even when i was made the
starter you know i might want to say
something to the team
but i would still kind of look out of
the corner of my eye that brad johnson
would be like is that okay did i say
that you know because i just had too
much respect for him first off i was a
young man that was raised to be
respectful to your to your elders and
people who had been there and done that
and put in hard work so i didn't want to
step on his toes or disrespect him in
any way and he couldn't have been better
with me and he you know
go ahead chris it's your team but i
still had a hard time just being that
guy with him being there so i do think
there is something to that and daniel
jones voice will be much louder and his
presence in the locker room will be much
bigger this year
but here's the thing
and i think about eli manning and as you
said he was always kind of a calm and
confident guy at times he was criticized
for not being vocal enough for not being
that voice one of the reasons why obj
was off the rails from time to time
there wasn't a quarterback who was
dropping f-bombs and getting in people's
faces and holding guys accountable do we
think chris that daniel jones is going
to be that guy now that he doesn't have
the shadow of eli manning to hold him in
place or is he going to be
kind of like what he learned from
watching eli manning last year
well i you know i yes he's not going to
change the person he is to what you're
saying mike that's that's a very good
question you're right no i don't think
now that eli's there he's going to be
hey you get in the huddle hey this guy
do that what are you doing but where i
think it'll change is if he notices
practice is a little lethargic or not
going well last year he might have just
sat back and remember like okay one of
you veterans are going to say something
this year he might speak up to the team
or say you know hold on coach and you
know talk to the offense to just go come
on guys we're better than this whatever
it may be or whether it's just reaching
out to the wide receivers in the locker
room and going hey let's go watch film
you know little things like that i don't
think it's necessarily going to be the
ra ra stuff but he's just going to be
emboldened with a bigger chest to know
i'm the guy this year i'm the man the
organization is invested in me i know i
can play and you don't have to worry
about ruffling feathers or stepping on
toes of a of a great nfl legend like
like eli manning
peter yeah sometimes
segment
we had
either peter or i just kind of fall off
the bike but peter let me ask you this
how much does the dynamic change now
that there's a new coach that's the
other factor in all this because daniel
jones just spent a year deferring to eli
manning and now you've also got a new
coach there new staff
and it's going to complicate it in a
different way for daniel jones he he
doesn't have to worry about eli manning
but now he's got to worry about getting
properly ensconced with a new staff at a
time when they can't get in the building
until who knows when
that's the biggest issue of all in my
column this week mike i did something
with james kampen the new offensive line
coach of the los angeles chargers
getting used to
meeting and knowing all his 13 veteran
guys who are going to training camp with
them if there is a camp via zoom and not
meeting any of them in person being
they're all there's 13 guys in three
different time zones
so
but anyway we talked about that and it's
the same way
this year
for everybody associated with the new
york giants and with so many other teams
that have new position coaches new head
coaches or both
i don't think this is a terrible thing
for daniel jones to have
you know the slate wipe totally clean
with a new coaching staff where it will
be a problem
is if there are continuing issues
with turning over members of the staff
brian flores in miami took chad o'shea
from new england didn't work out so now
all of that has to change because now
there's a new offensive system with chan
galey so you know what has to happen is
that you've got to start
you've got to you've you gotta do
something that's going to last for two
or three or four years so that every
year you're not starting from scratch
that to me is the biggest issue that
daniel jones has to make sure that that
it doesn't get to be like a josh rosen
deal where in the last seven years of
his football life he's had seven
different offensive coordinators
mike mike i think there's oh sorry i go
just to piggyback off of what he's
saying too you know and the question you
raise
you know yes peter's right we don't want
consistent coaching changes for a guy
like daniel jones but i do think the new
coaching change is actually going to be
a positive for him it's a regime change
this is you know it's no longer eli
manning's team it's just an all-new
focus of all right it's joe judge and
daniel jones and joe judge he's going to
go back or already has gone back and
watched last year's film and he's going
to know when he watches it go man daniel
jones is really good i mean you know i
wouldn't mind being tied to the hip with
this guy for a long long time so he's
going to bring energy to the building
and i think he'll embolden daniel jones
too to be that leader you know because
hey let's start this new era together
you're my quarterback you're my guy and
joe judge has an incredible energy about
him anyways to where you know i think in
a lot of ways it's going to be positive
for daniel jones to start this new era
this way
and everything you guys said makes
perfect sense i like it i agree i can
sign off on it but i'm sitting here
remembering that it's now regarded as a
given that general manager dave
gettleman is on the hot seat this year
which doesn't fit with this idea of
continuity because you get a new gm you
know what's going to happen the gm is
going to be looking to make changes to
get his people in there here's hoping
they do enough so they can keep the gm
in place keep the coaching staff in
place and let this percolate a little
bit and see what the giants can be
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports